You’re on a road trip - the kind that stretches
over days on end, and you need to make multiple
stops along the way to refuel the car and
yourself.
The last time you remember stopping to get
more gas and a bite to eat was back in Wyoming,
and now, you’re in the heart of Montana.
Thankfully, like an oasis in the desert, you
see the town of Clear Water off in the distance.
It’s a vibrant, welcoming little place,
a perfect slice of classic, small-town Americana.
You took a similar trip last year, and vaguely
remembered stopping at Clear Water that time
too and you’re glad to be back.
In particular, you remember the Old Prairie
Diner, a folksy little place with the most
delicious Huckleberry Pie you ever tasted.
Perhaps it’s about time for you to give
it another try.
You fill up your tank and stop at the diner.
The food tastes just as good as you remember,
but one thing is off: The entire staff seems
to have changed.
It’s the exact same diner you ate in a year
ago, no doubt about that, but it looks like
everyone from the wait staff to the cashier
to the cooks have all been replaced.
You try your best not to think about it, after
all, businesses are allowed to replace their
staff, but the longer you sit in the diner,
the more uncomfortable the feelings become.
You need to ask someone, just to push away
the fears that you’re going crazy.
When a waiter passes by, you compliment the
food, and mention that you ate here last year
too.
You ask the unfamiliar waiter if they had
worked here back then.
They confirm that, yes, they’ve always worked
here - and so has everybody else.
The diner is a family business.
You leave town not too long after that, feeling
vaguely unsettled, and as a voice on the radio
warns about the incoming rain, you tell yourself
that you never want to return to the town
of Clear Water, Montana.
As you leave, the memory of the town seems
to fade from your mind in real time, but little
do you know, the people of Clear Water will
never be able to leave.
Ever.
It’s because something horrifying will happen
in Clear Water every single year, and that
thing is known to the SCP Foundation as SCP-3300.
This annual anomalous event is Clear Water’s
own local curse, always occurring around mid-June.
While many of the mechanics of this event
still elude the Foundation’s understanding,
the outcome is well-documented: Every single
inhabitant of the town is replaced by a person
who didn’t previously exist.
While some elements may carry over from their
original counterparts, every person involved
will simply be a whole new person, with no
memories of the change or who they once were.
The process known as SCP-3300 lasts between
six and eighteen days, and once the process
has begun, it’s impossible for any outsiders
to intervene.
It begins with rain - a light, dreary drizzle
at first, but each day, the rain gets worse.
Soon, it’s a storm, and then, a maelstrom.
Flooding, hurricanes, tornadoes, all centered
around Clear Water, but cutting off neatly
just beyond it.
What happens in Clear Water remains in Clear
Water, and when the process has concluded
and the sun shines once more, everybody has
been changed .
Whenever the Foundation has tried to send
personnel or equipment into Clear Water during
SCP-3300, one of two things have happened:
In the more favorable scenarios, those attempting
to enter Clear Water have simply appeared
on the other side of the city limits.
In the less positive instances, personnel
and equipment have been lost forever within.
There is no stopping or even understanding
SCP-3300.
According to Foundation records, Clear Water
has been around at least as long as the Foundation
itself, perhaps even longer.
Clear Water has been able to undergo its yearly
nightmare without intrusion due to a unique
cognitohazardous effect, which creates a kind
of mental block around memories of the town
for outsiders.
You won’t forget Clear Water, per se, but
you will find it increasingly hard to focus
on.
Like something you can only ever see out of
the corner of your eye.
There is no saving the people of Clear Water.
The horror will play out again and again and
again…
The Foundation has no first-hand knowledge
of what happens in Clear Water during those
horrifying eighteen days.
But one account they have hints at a terrifying
possibility.
During an excursion into Clear Water, the
Foundation managed to collect a diary belonging
to a woman named Margaret Lane.
To the best of our knowledge, Margaret Lane
no longer exists, but if the contents of her
diary are to be believed, then what goes on
in Clear Water during SCP-3300 is far worse
than we’d ever imagined.
Margaret first started her diary not long
before SCP-3300’s 1995 iteration began.
She was in the middle of a tumultuous time
in her life - freshly clean from alcohol and
drug addiction, forced to live with her antagonistic
mother, and having peculiar and distressing
dreams.
In the first dream Margaret recorded, she
was...someone else, a woman living in a small
hut perhaps a century ago or more.
It was plague time.
She was looking down upon her daughter, bedridden,
her skin covered in painful-looking red blotches.
Her husband was already dead.
That’s when another man enters, a healthy
man.
He tells her that he’s found their salvation.
And then the dream ended.
Margaret woke up to a gray, dreary day.
There were clouds on the horizon.
The rain was coming.
It drizzled for the next few days, before
getting more intense - as one would expect
from an SCP-3300 cycle.
Of course, nothing seemed out of place to
Margaret.
Life carried on - she continued to stay clean,
resisting the offers of her old dealer, though
her relationship with her mother remained
frosty.
The rain started to get worse as voices on
the radio insisted that conditions would continue
to become more severe over the next few days.
They tried their best to maintain normality;
Margaret invited some friends - Jared, Sam,
Mike, and Isabel - to come over and play D&D
at her place.
That was when all hell broke loose.
While the group roleplayed, there was a furious
banging at the door, like whoever was knocking
was trying to bash the door down.
When Margaret’s mom opened the door to investigate
the commotion, she saw that an entire family
was standing there - a father, a mother, and
two young children.
The father immediately began furiously asking
why all these strangers were in his house.
When Margaret’s mother tried to tell him
that this wasn’t his house, he became increasingly
agitated, and walked straight into the home.
Margaret’s friends attempted to subdue him,
but he threw them off, displaying a supernatural
strength.
Margaret’s mom ran in with a golf club and
struck the mysterious man in the chest.
There was a nasty splat, but he didn’t seem
to react.
The golf club was just embedded in his chest,
having broken the skin and sunken in.
But there was no blood.
Just dripping water.
The father then pulled the golf club out of
his chest, and began beating Margaret’s
mother to death with it, all the while repeating
“My house” again and again, while his
wife and children watched with broad, sunny
smiles in the rain.
Somehow, Margaret knew that her mother was
beyond saving, and that there was no way of
defeating these things in a physical confrontation.
All they could do was run out to Jared’s
van with the rest of the group and high tail
it to the police station.
But when they arrived at the station, the
doors were barred and it appeared empty.
As the torrential rain hammered down from
above, there was nothing left to do but drive
out of town and try to escape whatever madness
was going on here.
But that was easier said than done.
They drove for what seemed like hours on end
as the rain and the howling wind persisted.
Jared had been injured during the fight with
the strange family and his health deteriorated
further as the drive stretched on.
They should have left the town of Clear Water
a long time ago, but it seemed like they were
nowhere.
It wasn’t long before Jared was lying dead
in the back of the van, and now, there were
only four of them left.
They kept driving - afraid, grieving, hungry,
and tired - and Margaret took the opportunity
to sleep.
It was no time to rest, but she was so exhausted
that she had no choice.
Margaret had a continuation of her earlier
dream.
The different her, the dream her, was laying
the plague-ridden body of her daughter in
the river.
But she wasn’t the only one.
All the villages of her settlement were placing
the bodies of their dead in the river, as
the water washed around them and through them.
The bodies became one with the water, and
then, they became the water.
The water was everything.
When Margaret awoke, it was to the horrible
sounds of bubbling and boiling.
That’s when she saw that Jared’s body
was...dissolving.
No, not dissolving, evaporating.
It was bubbling and convulsing, like it was
made of water, until the entire thing burst
into a cascade of hot steam.
After that, Margaret and the others left the
vehicle and refused to get back inside.
Nothing was making sense.
It was like something out of a nightmare.
As they walked, the rain hammered down upon
them.
They couldn’t have been walking for more
than a mile when they crashed into something.
It was a sign - “Welcome to Clear Water.”
It was like the town itself had drawn them
back.
Mike refused to return to the town of his
own free will, and began walking in the other
direction.
Moments later, he was walking back towards
them in silence, though he’d never intended
to.
SCP-3300 had distorted his path, and brought
him back.
It was clear that Mike was shaken to the core
by the experience, but they had to press on.
They would head to the grocery store for food
and then to a sporting goods store where they
could hopefully grab some guns to fight the
violent, altered people who’d somehow appeared
with the rain.
But things didn’t go to plan - or what little
plan there even was.
Mike shot himself on the first night at Dirk’s
Sporting Goods, leaving only Margaret, Sam,
and Isabel alive.
Perhaps one of the most terrifying details
of Mike’s death was the fact he didn’t
even bleed, instead, the gaping exit wound
in the back of his head was just full of water.
Water was all that seemed to be left of them.
Sam, seemingly driven to the edge by the sight
of Mike’s death, grabbed a hunting knife
to perform an experiment.
She cut into her own skin, and was horrified
to see only water dripping out.
They’d all been “changed”, and they
didn’t know why.
That’s when the survivors noticed something
else: There were people standing outside in
the rain, hundreds of them.
Not a single one they could recognize, all
new people.
Waiting.
Sam said only one word, “Outside”, before
walking out of the hunting goods store and
disappearing into the crowd and the rain,
never to be seen again.
Margaret mused that perhaps, in the end, she
had the right idea.
To be taken, killed, erased, or changed would
be inevitable.
In the final entry in Margaret’s diary,
dreams blend with reality as her mind finally
gives out from the terror.
She realizes, in her final moments, that there
is no way out.
There is no escape.
There is only water.
Water is eternal.
The rain is eternal.
All will be changed.
And given the fact that no trace of Margaret
was ever found, save for her diary, all her
fears turned out to be right.
She was taken and replaced by SCP-3300, just
as will inevitably happen to all the current
citizens of Clear Water the next time SCP-3300
rolls around.
It will be as inevitable and as indifferent
to those it affects as tomorrow’s sunrise.
You cannot change the rain, but believe us,
in Clear Water, Montana, the rain can change
you.
Now check out “SCP-2000 - Deus Ex Machina”
and “SCP-3001 - Red Reality” for more
anomalies that’ll make you see the world
a little differently...